all right so for my talk of the table we
look ahead to sunday when people will
fill the streets of new york city
for one of the largest annual pride
marches in the world
many of this year's events will also be
virtual the new york city pride parade
is a massive celebration inspiring the
fight
for lgbtq plus equality it began after
the stonewall uprising in 1969
when police raided a gay bar in the city
pride celebrations are also taking place
in other cities this month we spoke with
the parents of lgbtq plus kids and
adults about their journeys
and how they are proud as well
[Music]
this is my favorite picture of namdi
that's my baby all up in their glory
when they were
16 they came out as gay but
when they were graduating from stanford
last
summer i was made to understand that
they were non-binary
and their preferred pronouns are they
them theirs
i was a little shocked and even maybe a
little scared what does that mean
i had to quickly get with the program
we knew that natalie was discovering
something about herself
at about 12 or 13 she came up and said
how would i feel if she was a lesbian we
didn't have any problem
cooper is gender non-conforming which
means
the way he expresses himself to the
world
is what we stereotypically call female
but he's very admit he's a boy
magdy came up to me and said that
she kind of like boys and girls
we have another son who had told us
like two three years before that he was
gay and
it was shocking we got to the point of
saying hey they're our children
and no matter what they are we love them
we respect them
and we're going to accept them the way
they are
[Music]
everything that i wanted for my daughter
to
succeed in life she can still have just
because she's not going to have a
husband she'll have a wife
instead doesn't mean that she can't have
everything that she wants
the newborn picture i took of him he's
wearing a blue onesie and he has a
football next to him
in my mind i had cooper going on the
same journey as my older son
having a child like cooper has really
made me realize
that our children are born the way they
are
if your child comes out to you as queer
then you should be glad and thankful
that you've
created a safe space in your heart and
in your home
the world can be kind of hard on you
sometimes
especially when people think you're
different homophobia is real
transphobia is real lesbophobia all
those things are real
but your love and your understanding and
your acceptance
to me is a lethal weapon against those
things
i wish that everybody would respect them
as human beings forty percent of
children like mine
attempt suicide i decided that i was not
going to be my child's first bully
that i was going to be there to support
him and make sure that he knew
that he was going to survive
and thrive
[Music]
i'm proud of namdi because not only have
they challenged me
they've also taught me what i do is
empower my child to go out every day and
just
have no apologies for being bold and
black and beautiful
magdeep has been a productive citizen
a very loving daughter and she has made
us
grandparents i love her
creativity love her confidence i really
do love the fact that she is who she is
and she doesn't let anybody tell her
differently
cooper is sassy and he
is smart and he is kind and he really
just
embraces life for what it is
my name is rafael ultado my name is
magdalena ortado
and we are the proud parents of three
lgbtq children including magdy
and my grandson my name is jennifer
solomon
and the proud parent of cooper my name
is dr lulu and i'm the proud parent of
my young adult
namdi my name is christy sanchez and i'm
a proud parent of natalie
[Music]
how lucky and blessed are these kids to
have parents like that
it's an amazing story it is it's really
wonderful to see how supportive they are
and i love
what the one parent said the doctor who
said love and understanding is a lethal
weapon
yeah you know parents have expectations
for their kids no matter what and you
just have to realize they come out they
are who they are yeah
out of the way just get out of the way